this has been a remarkably busy week for
doctors at this military clinic in
central Morocco
patients suffering from anxiety and
panic attacks are brought to its
emergency rooms
the aftershocks and memories of last
five days earthquake have left their
marks on these people who are clearly
traumatized is
she lost her house and relatives and
fears what happens next in her life
we were asleep when I had a strange
sound and I started screaming the roof
was falling I shouted to my husband to
rescue the children and my mother it was
terrible long tough hours went by I felt
alone and helpless
as roads are being cleared ambulances
are getting more access to most of the
affected villagers
this hospital is in the middle between
the city of Marrakesh and the epicenter
of the earthquake it was crucial during
the rescue operations and continues to
be the main facility for those who lost
their homes and are now living in
temporary makeshift camps around the
area and along the devastated Zone 40
markia lives on her own her Village has
suffered extensive damage
traumatized she does not remember
anything lying next to her
islazram a 90 year old woman from the
town of asni she has a spine injury and
is yet to have a surgery
we suffer a lot we lost everything
relatives and belongings I'm fine but I
just want the authorities to build a
house for my mother we are a family 24
people in the same place that place no
longer exists
the most critical cases are taken to
bigger hospitals the authorities say
this emergency operation is not
affecting the routine workflow at other
medical facilities in the region
we initially had to deal with a huge
number of people suffering serious
injuries particularly fractures and deep
wounds but now we have more teams more
facilities established everywhere
for the children who went through the
horrific seconds of the earthquake but
felt much longer a cheerful moment at a
makeshift playground
a little break from their tough reality
south of maracash
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera